er natürlich wieder voll happy dass das
windrad das große ziel die letzten jahre
und mehr uns wirklich durchziehen können
um die medaille gemacht deswegen
überglücklich großen dank an unseren
arbeitgeber als bundesheer
sensationelles umfeld oder sensationelle
unterstützung des berühmten vertreters
das ja jemand hinter mir steht und da
kann man sich schon sehr gezielt und in
ruhe auf solche aufgaben vorbereiten und
ich habe erfolg gibt uns recht
abonniere zur goldmedaille schon
realisiert ja mittlerweile schon weil
das beherrschen 20 fragt man also wäre
es schön langsam dass man das realisiert
den kontoauszug welchen beitrag hat
eigentlich das hessische bundesheer für
diesen erfolg natürlich auch sehr mainz
ps3 war dabei und es war ich mal stütze
und es war immer gut auf meinen sport
konzentrieren können
und jetzt benni dort wohin will ja man
kann sie einfach nicht zur goldmedaille
bei olympischen spiele abholen kann man
bestellen
also ich habe einfach nur hart dafür
trainiert und er wusste kann nur
medaille mitkämpfen mit der farm dia und
sehr es ist aber total cool dass es so
aufgegangen ist und das ist einfach
durch zone
bin natürlich sehr zufrieden war schon
sehr lange unterstützt vom
österreichischen bundesheer und fallen
ihr die unterstützung kriegt in der zeit
was meine gegangen ist dass oliver
verletzt und in der zeit des bundes
entstanden benjamin kalkuliere zur
großmodelle ja sehr gut jetzt eine
kleine tochter die sie erst einmal
wieder am rücken seit zwei wochen
ich bin überglücklich das bundesheer den
ersten stein auf jeden fall mal dazu
beigetragen weil sie hätten im
bundesheer im leistungssport damals
nicht weiter ausführen können
und es hat mir jetzt wunderbar golf über
über gute und schlechte zeiten
ich bin natürlich besonders stolz auf
meine athletinnen und athleten wenn ich
das in dieser form sagen darf sie haben
hervorragendes geleistet sie haben
spitzenergebnisse erzielt und damit
deutlich unter beweis gestellt dass an
der wintersportnation österreich kein
weg vorbeiführt